comment l'auteur d'un témoignage d'un
essai d'un document et ce soir c'est
carte zéro
ce soir pour annoncer la création du
club de ceux qui se sont fait piquer
leur job par Laurence Ferrari
qui font des implants aussi
alors désormais car vous animez un
talk-show tous les soirs de 22h à 23h
sur BFM TV c'est sur quelle chaîne car
zéro sur BFM TV
[Musique]
et
puis il
est il
a compris
et donc son électorat sont des gens qui
on appelle le l'Amérique profonde et
redneck et sont des gens qui si si on ne
connaît pas le nom des présidents
étranger ou que on fait les lapsus ou
qu'on a l'air un peu Google le temps en
temps mais au contraire on est proche
des gens et en cela il a même été réélu
3 million de voix d'avance la deuxième
fois là pour nous expliquer ici en
France que c'est un crétin ce n'est pas
du tout un crétin il est pas hyper
intelligent mais il est malin il a
réussi exactement ce qu'il voulait il va
partir et tu m'en diras quel crétin il a
tout raté il a tout réussi à les
États-Unis alors rende première
puissance mondiale et il a été réaliste
pour son pays et on peut pas ça lui
jeter à la gueule on peut dire que pour
nous c'est horrible et que ce qu'il a
fait en Irak c'est ignoble et qui se
feront demain puis que ce soit en Iran
ça sera ignoble mais par contre on peut
pas lui dire qu'il n'a pas été efficace
il a été enfin il a amené son pays dans
la guerre en Irak il a il a il a eu 4000
morts américains des centaines de
milliers de mourir mais ça non plus pour
lui ça non plus il a pris les réserves
tu sais c'est comme la fin de la partie
de Monopoly reste la rue Lecourbe
[Applaudissements]
j'en sais pas si bouche est un con mais
Karl Zéro et évidemment
le 11 septembre pour lui c'est la bonne
surprise en fait c'est la divine
surprise
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as un souvenir de ce qu'il
a fait
et
alors
énormément
il a raison c'est qu'en France on est
toujours favorable celui qui va perdre
donc là comme tout le monde aime Obama
du monde pour les Américains
il a raison quand même c'est vrai que en
décembre 2001 quand qu'on bouge fait
level après Sidi pour Laura et moi
l'année 2001 aura été fantastique
septembre il raconte le truc il déconne
et puis ça a été une journée
intéressante
objectif de George Bush c'est Saddam
Hussein il combat tout ce qui ressemble
de près ou loin en islamiste un barbu et
donc il va grâce au 11 septembre il va
aller en Irak je me dis c'est quand même
bizarre en plus c'est quand même bien la
CIA ils sont censés tout courant de ce
qui se passe quand tu as 19 mecs qui
déboule pour prendre des cours de
pilotage en apprenant juste à décoller
même pas atterrir
sont pas prévenu
services secrets français
non non non
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi Julien
cette histoire du 11 septembre
je suis sceptique. Chaque fois qu'on
parle de complot suis un peu sceptique
le chef d'orchestre à visible tout ça
j'ai pas beaucoup
de la main occulte
pour
les États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
car j'ai un autre coupe dans le film si
vous me croyez pas du tout à la fois à
la foi chrétienne de George Bush moi j'y
crois pas parce que quelqu'un qui a la
foi c'est pas quelqu'un qui a l'air
qu'on puisse tu es autant de gens
du bien je crois qu'il est surtout
pragmatique et qui s'est dit il a vu
tout l'intérêt qu'il pouvait en tirer de
cette droite chrétienne électoralement
et au niveau de ce qui pourrait grâce à
eux piquer comme pognon parce que il y a
aussi ça il y a tout l'aspect de tout
en même temps il est il est
à
moins que on propose un thé au polonium
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu